but what they said that if they initiate
the hug then that's on them to break to
be sinful if they go right the whole
time you're like Kiana you're like just
yeah you're orbiting these you do that I
went like this when they try to hug me
[Music]
uh do you guys know about what happened
over in Malaysia during a music festival
where
um there's this band called The 1975 and
they have a singer named Matt Healy so
uh they're in the middle of a concert
mid performance he starts ranting about
how uh you know Malaysia it kind of
doesn't have the best
I guess lies
in the advantage of or in favor of gay
people I think that's an understatement
yeah I'm starting a real real mild
they're not that chill about game
they're actually second I guess it's
some kind of rating they're number two
for like the worst place to live if
you're like trans number one I wonder
but
um so they're headliner Festival
The 1975 right in the middle of it he
starts saying like uh
um he starts saying I don't see the
point of inviting The 1975 to a country
and then telling us who we can have sex
with so he's on the mic saying this [__]
and then he is he American I think he's
British but he made out what is yeah
that's what's coming next oh so he grabs
he grabs a dude his uh band mate and
they start kissing on stage
yeah as a demonstration and in his mind
he's like helping the situation yeah is
he alive right now he's a rock star dude
he just got banned from Malaysia yeah so
he they get banned and then also they
shut the festival down and everyone else
who is supposed to perform doesn't get
to like Ty Dolla Sign kid Leroy Strokes
it's just over vessel's done everyone
who paid you don't get your money back
done
and then they just fly out and they
leave so there's a situation going where
there are some people that maybe look at
it from the outside like especially
people here that go oh yeah that's
you're championing it for us but then
there's people in Malaysia who are gay
and they're like well thanks [__]
now we can't even [__] go anywhere
there's a Crackdown yeah now you've like
come in and disrupted our ecosystem you
don't have to live in as an outsider and
you peace out so there's like two sides
going on and we didn't get to see Ty
Dolla Sign yeah because I'm more for
that side
when you go into someone else's house
and some like let's say your dad's like
you know like yelling at you and then
you
[__] roast the [__] out of their dad
anyway I helped you out you know and you
leave your dad's gonna beat the [__] out
of you like you gotta like there's
little ecosystems and it's like man you
gotta protect them you know I uh I
commented on this next shark article it
was mad it was [__] magical
what I found out because I don't know
this group right but um apparently
they've been an issue prior to this yeah
they've had other [__] in South Korea
they did something really [__] up
I forgot exactly what but it was enough
to wear
um it wasn't gay stuff it was something
that was like disrespectful to the
culture like he made comments or
something like that and then he was
getting canceled out there
and so a lot of so so the sentiment I
got was a lot of people on on the
comments were like why would you bring
this like guy that's already shown
cultural insensitivities toward Asians
to Malaysia and expect that he'll
respect any culture yeah because he's
coming at it as like oh we're Superior
westerners and our morality is better
than yours so let me show you how we do
it in the west and then he kisses his
[__] boyfriend that's that's what
that comes from and that always works
out great now the debate is between like
what is considered human rights and what
is considered religious uh uh expression
and freedom yeah yeah yeah and I think
we're having the same debate here but
out there it's a lot more
um
ruthless because it's old school you
know like
I know that um also you don't live there
either they also have different rules so
when when we were out there
there's rules for Muslims in the Sharia
law but the Chinese citizens of Malaysia
and the secular community in Malaysia
they're not subject they're not subject
to the same rules
so that's I might be wrong here but I
remember specifically being told that
during Ramadan there's a Muslim police
that goes to the clubs and they check
your ID morality police and then they're
like oh you're Muslim you're in trouble
because they'll they'll like the malays
are under that law but they don't give a
[__] about the [__] Chinese or
anybody else if you want to go to hell
you go to hell but they don't go to jail
for drinking during Ramadan or whatever
yeah so there might be some kind of
thing there where it's like hey if
you're a Muslim Malay then you can't get
caught but I also know on top of that a
lot of Muslim countries have PDA laws
where even if you're straight making out
you get in trouble so it's not just a
gay thing it's like if you're straight
making out if you're straight showing
PDA whatever you also get in trouble but
if you're gay it's obviously worse it
probably is but but also it's woke so
then you go broke
shout out to
things that rhyme
I'm sorry but that's the thing like
these these concert goers they paid a
ticket right and then you know the guy
went walking they went bro everyone lost
it it definitely does suck to to not
have to live in the environment that you
like create like if you made a hostility
occur and then all right guys later well
what's that I mean there's a line
between human rights
and just courtesy because for example
when we went to Malaysia we were told
girls with the hijab don't initiate hugs
and yeah they're like don't like we like
we hug our fans or whatever right but
then I I could have been like no I have
every [__] right yeah to make sweet
love to my fan base whatever the [__] I
want if they were I [__] the fence
that's what I do it's my it's who I am
and then you could have thrown off and I
could have been like other people I
could have been like American Freedom
[__] and then I just [__] make out
what a girl oh my Lord Big Time fan I
could have but I respected the culture
and what we did was of course we did air
high fives something something
but what they said that if they initiate
the hug then that's on them to break to
be sinful if they go right yeah the
whole time you're like Kiana you're like
just [__] yeah yeah you're orbiting
these [__] I went like this when they
try to hug me
yeah but then but that yeah I could have
been like no this is my relationship
with my fans and in America I can
[__] hug all my fans or I could have
been like well I know that's how they do
things here
I don't get it but I respect it you know
or like you could have been in the
Muslim country for example and be like
no abortions I'm from [__] Florida
mic drop and they would have been like
yeah that's my culture yeah yeah and
then people like yeah that's it yeah so
a lot of people look at it like it's
saviorism he's annoying he thinks he
gets to go in and do that but I think
it's a leave yeah I think it's all right
that's the part there's no consequence
yeah yeah it's like if you moved to a
country that didn't have the justices
that were you know representative of you
and your identity then maybe making a
change makes more sense because you've
lived there and this dude's probably
like bragging about it back home like
yeah dude I got kicked out of Malaysia
but if you just look at a different
country and you're like oh they
shouldn't be living like that and you go
over there and you [__] do this yeah
and then you leave it's like he thinks
he's trailblazing something yeah I
looked it up too and to see like what
laws were like legit if they if being
gay was illegal and apparently
um it's under the sodomy law that they
have and it's been struck down like
seven years ago or something so their
federal court system said that
um that's actually no longer illegal
because a guy
there was a raid a gay raid or something
and then they were caught doing butt sex
but [__] each other right no and then
he appealed it at that moment he
appealed it I think it was 2007 or
something but you know those cases take
a long time when it gets to the Supreme
Court he appealed it and then I guess
they the the federal system out there in
Malaysia they they said oh actually it's
not illegal to do butt sex they changed
the law for that guy they don't have
anti-sodomy laws anymore so then people
that are quoting it was overturned right
because it's it's it's it's
um outdated on Wikipedia if you look it
up on Wikipedia versus gay World versus
no the sodomy laws were the bottom
right and then they got topped yeah that
makes sense yeah yeah yeah but
apparently yeah it's been it's been it's
it's the street yeah yeah
it's no longer a thing yeah
dude it is so [__] up to like think
your country has the best [__] laws
and then you just want to spread that
[__] that's kind of funny to me it's so
presumptive yeah it is it's kind of
American because you usually go to like
someone else's home and you're like oh
they got their own rules whatever you're
just like normal person what the [__] is
this [__] cereal in the pantry no you
leave it on the counter dude
yeah I don't I don't take my [__]
shoes off I'll tell you that I'm not
gonna take my [__] shoes off okay but
I gotta go that Rule's not for me yeah
yeah and it's I like the 1975 too that's
good really yeah I actually like this
band
they are really good
I did read some stuff from like the gay
malaise what they were saying what was
the game Malaysia same thing like what
what Ryan was mentioning how it's like
it's [__] up that we have our own like
progress that we're trying to do and
these guys coming in and just ruining it
taking us backwards whatever it's like
in cop movies when the [__] FBI moves
in on what the cops are doing and
they're like oh my God we've been
working on this cake for eight years
we're taking over yeah he's out of your
jersey we have jurisdiction exactly it's
like they might have they don't make eye
contact yeah showing the badge yeah
because what if they do have their way
of infiltrating the system and making
they're like in a way that's easy for
everyone and then you get taken off the
case bro oh and then you gotta work not
to be Renegade yeah dude you gotta be a
renegade and at the same time they're
finessing they're finessing the powers
at that b and they're like oh let's not
do like uh pull the Band-Aid off
straight away let's like kind of like
smoothly get this transition going and
then some band comes in [__] overseas
and does this yeah and then there's all
there's also another group that we're
saying like you know it does it does
suck to just see how the world is
accepting it but like in my own home
country like we have to be hidden and
like afraid and then like because it's
even if it might be legal now there's
still the social stigma and the violence
right that they that's inflicted on the
gay community I do think that no culture
can speak to you better than your own
culture though yeah yeah so if you have
a guy from the outside coming in it just
would probably make everyone just mad
yep well didn't didn't insync tour there
in Malaysia and they're pretty gay yeah
and all they got to do is do shape in my
heart or whatever yeah or I think it was
Backstreet Boys but yeah you just do
shave in my heart that's as gay as
semi-suggestive gay you know what I mean
that's not not quite explicit yeah
you're not exactly like
buttholes but you might as well be like
like there's a couple degrees in between
there but I see where you're going with
you know what I'm saying but they were
doing it they were basically doing a pro
gay message on tour and they didn't have
to be so over the [__] head with it
you mean like fingerings those buttholes
yeah you there's more incognito mode
yeah and that allowed the message to
promulgate more and allow more maybe
like tie-dye jeans or like faded jeans
or like all that kind of stuff people
were able to wear those more crop top
shirts wet shirts crop top shirts
fishnet jewelry disco ball one ear
earring frosted tips shorts really
hygiene shorts exactly and all that was
fine dude's wearing bracelets and being
like Oh I thought this was a watch I
have to wash jeans exactly yeah that's
that's the rough part man but what did
Ty Dolla Sign say about this
did all the artists get paid still or I
don't know what did Ty Dolla signs say
about this right
like as when he was in The Green Room
what do they what do they hear him say
check does it say yeah no I'm just
trying to look up I feel like he was
busy in the Green Room eating his Roti
because they have some fire ass Roti out
there he said I messed with white girls
Asian girls Spanish girls black girls
everything literally everything
everything that's my guy dude what a
good statement
I miss all girls
[Music]